[Music]
it's become an all too common scene
Haitian refugees detained in the
Dominican Republic
we met them in this military base in the
havon right at the border
they're being sent back to Haiti even
those who say they've built new lives
here my husband works in a construction
site and I was cooking at home when the
police arrived they wouldn't let me get
my baby's clothes I left all my money at
home and I have nothing here Security
Forces here are telling us that most of
his people were detained trying to enter
the country legally but some of these
women are telling me that they have
homes here and that their children were
born in the Dominican Republic
Miranda pieres with her eight-year-old
son
she shows us his birth certificate that
proves he was born in the Dominican
Republic
my son has a birth certificate he was
born here they cannot send him back to
Haiti the U.N has called on the
Dominican Republic to hold deportations
Haiti is in the midst of a political
crisis that has gangs controlling large
parts of the country thousands are
fleeing
lack of available Health Care Services
in Haiti have forced pregnant women to
cross the border to deliver their
children but many are not allowed inside
Dominican hospitals and some have had
their children on the street human
rights activists say they're alarmed
about what they call our president Luis
Arena's persecution of Haitians in his
country
there are massive deportations and the
cases are not individual there's no due
process there's children with papers
others with just visas it's just massive
and a scandal even pregnant women being
sent back to Haiti and the law says that
shouldn't be done the Dominican Republic
is building a wall to protect its
borders from Smugglers but also illegal
migrants
foreign
and cannot allow everyone in the only
mechanism the Dominican Republic has is
to show that it will not tolerate
migrant irregularity of the deportations
and this is what we are doing this has
nothing to do with ethnical reasons or
racism that's another problem if the
state stops all deportations we do not
know what could happen here
is facing its worst crisis in years
human rights groups say its people are
being discriminated against across the
region and they're asking the Dominican
Republic among other governments for
empathy for those who are trying to
escape hunger violence and have no place
to go
on the Haitian border